but here's my problem
is
once i
uh
would you send me
send it to me when you get a chance
okay thank you for her special to you
okay cool thank you
i i will know more here
uh probably just like across the street
okay
is
um
shut up
good night
all right guys
as someone blessed from be from a
district as i am
uh with large aapi population and
community
uh this is something that i see
regularly and i'm therefore very
grateful to congresswoman grace ming
and senator maisie hirano for their
leadership
there are other leads in the house and
senate on it as well i thank them all
today we go to the white house for a
signing ceremony
for that legislation uh signal to our
nation of the high priority that
president biden has placed
uh on and the congress had placed on
addressing this issue as you know right
within
a day of his inauguration the president
brought this
up tasked the justice department to make
a further
record of this address the issue as well
even before we had an attorney general
and now we have the legislation
uh when he talked about covenant and
made his address to the nation he
included uh the attack uh
copa 19 hate crimes uh that we
uh have seen so again yesterday the
bipartisan support was passed
[Music]
for this legislation senate the house
the signing
uh tomorrow today so
yesterday again that was on justice and
security
yesterday as you know proudly the house
of representatives strong bipartisan way
passed a bipartisan uh
legislation for an independent
bipartisan 911 type
commission to establish the truth
of what happened on january 6.
it's important to note that this
legislation was done in a record time
you probably don't know but the
legislation
for 9 11 commission now 9 11 2001
was signed into law november 27
2002 more than 14 months
later we're very pleased that this
has a much accelerated pace to it and
we're eager
to get it to the president's desk again
it is
it was endorsed by chairs kane
and hamilton the co-chairs of the 9 11
commission
in the interest of bipartisanship we've
yielded on many requests but we would
not yield
on its purpose to defend our democracy
i i just wanted to uh just read from
general case you didn't see uh there's
we strongly
very strongly urge house members to
support hr
3233 the net bipartisan national
commission to investigate the january 6
attack on the capital
it goes on to say what it would
establish as chairman vice chairman of 9
11
commission unity of purpose was key to
the effectiveness of the group
where we put country above party without
bias the events before during and after
the attack
today democracy faces a new threat the
january 6 attack on the us capital
was one of the darkest days in the
history of our country
americans deserve an objective and
accurate account of what happened
as we did in the wake of september 11th
it's time
to set aside partisan politics come
together
as americans in common pursue common
common pursuit
of truth and just truth and justice so
we're very
very pleased that the number of
republicans who
voted for truth and justice
today the house continues our work to
protect the capital with an emergency
supplemental funding bill
it does it's based on the facts and
findings of the
uh of general honore's report general
honore had a task force of
national security and law enforcement
experts
who prioritized and sequenced
how we should proceed and also reflects
the
inspector general's reports to the
appropriation
house administration's committee the
funding will respond to the
cost to harden the capital
to repair the capital and then to harden
against future attacks
and it also honors the sacrifice of the
capitol police officers
including the howie liebengood center
for wellness
harry liebengood took his life following
9 11. his family
has been very concerned about the
counseling necessary for members faced
with such
a tragedy and it's beyond shameful
and beyond reason that any member
would not understand why we need this
and i want to make a special
shout out for the custodial staff of the
capitol this legislation
addresses the sacrifices that they have
made the needs that they have to go
forward
and i'm i'm pleased
that the appropriations committee found
the appropriate route to be helpful to
them
okay and all this is going on of course
we're
getting ready for the american jobs and
family plans
uh to build back better our chairs have
been working
hopefully as much as possible in a
bipartisan way to see where we can find
common ground from the standpoint of the
house committees as you know
the president has been in negotiations
with the senate republicans
we'll see where that takes us but we
do have a responsibility and an
opportunity to build back better
with the um not only what we want to do
for roads and bridges and mass transit
and high-speed rail but
a broadband broadband broadband into
rural america and into
urban deserts in that regard with water
projects so necessary as a person
in the west where water is uh can be a
fighting word
it is certainly a vital uh word and
source and
so we have uh for the whole country need
to
not only store distribute better
recycle but get the lead out for the
health
of our children and in order to build
back better we want to do so with much
more
larger participation of previously
underrepresented
communities and starting with moms
dads too who may need health care i mean
not child care
or elder care or care for persons with a
disability and their families
when people talk about people not taking
jobs now they have to recognize if kids
cannot be in school and children
and families cannot afford health care
and it's not readily
available how can people go to work
so again if we're going to build back
better we have to think in a new
way about what infrastructure is and
that
workforce development child care
family medical leave are all part of
that initiative
and so we're excited about what that
means and we're so happy about the child
tax credit and universal pre-k and
the the initiatives that the president
sees as
valuable uh to building our fisa it's
it's it's pretty exciting when you think
of the opportunity that is there
how we grow our economy with everyone
participate in a fuller way
and the benefits of of our hopefully
prosperity as as as we grow the economy
in a way that creates good-paying jobs
preserves the planet
involves many more people any questions
yes on the commission but first
yesterday what is that
you were loudest
um what did yesterday's vote tell you
about the state of the republican party
you know i'm not here to analyze the
republican party all i say is
to my republican friends and i do have
them take back your party
this is the grand old party the party
has done so much
for our country and quite frankly many
uh republicans
have courageously withstood uh
the shall we say assault on our
democracy that has gone forth when you
think of the republicans and the courage
that they've had
in the electoral system in our country
and election
decisions that have been made to support
uh support the fact that the election
was legitimate many republicans were the
ones who
came forward so i think that there's
some
courage that needs to be recognized in
the party
certainly in our body liz cheney and
others
but it's not for me to analyze them
except to say as one who has served with
republicans
for a long time in the congress this is
a different
i would say breed of cat but i love our
kitten daisy so i'm not going to say
breeder again
i would do that to get my granddaughters
uh they
fellas daisy but it is um it is
interesting to see uh
35 members coming forth i i'm very proud
of them and it was a recognition that
this was a bipartisan product
negotiated in good faith that all of a
sudden they wanted to say well if it
isn't
if it isn't uh black lives matter or
something like that
but taking their eye off the ball
january 6.
we saw the guy yesterday from the
capital defending position we saw
statements as well clarifying some of
that how does that
pertain though you know and i've asked
you about this before you know people
keep saying well when can congress get
back to normal
and the continuation of hybrid hearings
and
remote voting
uh attending physician and that's the
guidance we have to go by
uh said is unless that people are
vaccinated we have to continue to wear
masks
uh in our meetings and on on the floor
and so
that's what we are doing uh it is
unfortunate that
a large number of people in the congress
have refused to be
vaccinated or i don't know what it is i
don't know refused or
or have been vaccinated and don't want
to admit i don't know what that is
because i shouldn't know
it's it's their personal business but
until they as the doctor said
until they are vaccinated we cannot
have uh meetings without masks
what about committees wouldn't it be the
same
yeah well in the meetings if you uh if
you
don't if you're not vaccinated uh the
other people have to wear a mask
uh and we'll see i mean i'm hoping that
this new cdc guidance will
will encourage people to be vaccinated
we want to get through this as soon as
possible
you i mean does anybody feel like
wearing a mask
so no no we all want to get through this
and we want to get back to
a much of the containment of visitors to
the capitol
relates to cobit not
necessarily what happened january 6th
only i mean we have to protect people
and have safety and security
but many of the prohibitions of visits
sprang
well before january came forth before
january 6.
thank you just to follow up on that you
know the president has talked about july
4th this game may be this time when the
country can begin to
gather more and get back to normal do
you see any openings or
uh other aspects of the capital to
visitors
and again knowing that so many people
have not been vaccinated
do you just keep waiting for them or is
there an alternative we have to wait for
them to be vaccinated
because they are selfishly a danger to
other people including
staff people here uh so while we're all
hopeful and i
joined the president being hopeful uh
that we can reach a place
where it is safe for people to be what
is this the honor system
the honor system as to whether somebody
has been vaccinated
do you want them breathing in your face
on the strength of their honor
so let's just see let's just see i mean
again we have
this is about science and governance
and science and governance we have a
responsibility
to make sure of that the house of the
representatives
chamber is not a petri dish
for the because of the selfishness of
some not to be vaccinated
or to insist or to wear them at it
because it requires us to wear a mask i
mean we could come to a place where we
say
if you don't want to wear a mask and you
don't want to if you're not vaccinated
don't even come to the floor
we have facilities up above in the in
the gallery where people can come to
vote
we don't want to deter anybody's ability
to um
exercise their constitutional duties we
have that responsibility as well
so we're trying to balance everybody
being able to exercise their
his or her constitutional duties as well
as
protect the secure the staff the staff
uh and the other members now as um
i know a lot of things as speaker of the
house
i know a lot of things and i know a lot
about people's
predispositions and the rest because
they share them with me
and i have to make judgments based on
what the vulnerability are
of our members as well but
it's not a shall we say subjective
decision
the uh uh attending physician has said
until everybody's vaccinated
we wear masks yes ma'am
back from the commission um i know that
that is your strong preference for a
bipartisan
911 pet commission things are not
looking great for that passing
in the senate there's a lot of
opportunities are you committed to if
that fails in the state are you
committed to a select committee
how would that work we're taking this
one step at a time what we've said
we want is a bipartisan commission
i don't want to weaken that position
everybody knows what my options are
they are no secret but i
the preference not only preference
overwhelming preference is for
bipartisanship
and i do i don't i don't think that what
we've heard from the senate is so bad
compared to what we've usually hear from
the senate
and i'm very pleased with the statement
made by the majority leader
on this subject and now that some of the
senators republican senators are saying
well if there's
republicans can hire staff that would be
okay with that
of course they can hire staff that's
never even been a question
so we like that uh threshold that they
want the
committee to cross i just want to follow
up on that question
so it doesn't appear there's going to be
an investigation no matter what happens
right that's what basically what you're
saying is it's this it's something else
but
this congress is not going to go by
without some sort of large-scale probe
into
january 6. well let's go back to 911
when 911
you saw it took 14 and a half months to
get this signed by the president
did you know that isn't that surprising
to you
you would have thought just like that
but there was major opposition
to a 911 commission i know that because
i had the first bill
and i lost on the floor uh we were in
the minority at the time
the uh and then tim romer had the
amendment to the intelligence bill
with the help of the families and that's
how we got a bill passed
and then to the president's desk but it
took time
uh this has been really on an
accelerated pace even though
why don't we have it well it's in the
works and it takes time to negotiate
the uh in the meantime though in 2011
i mean excuse me uh 2001
and two leading up to that we had a
joint committee
in the house and senate bipartisan
committee of which i was a co-chair
as the top democrat on the intelligence
committee uh
bob graham was the chairman of the
intelligence committee in the senate so
he
he and shelby porter got pelosi
in the house and we had months of
hearings and the rest
and the work that was produced by that
committee was very valuable to the 911
commission and in the
legislation establishing it said it
should take advantage of all those
things
as we would hope uh that this commission
would take advantage of some of the
other
uh uh oversight committees
work so let's just hope that we can have
the clarity
of a bipartisan commission with
high-level
national leaders on it
as the committee calls for with
expertise in the areas
that are important whether it's
law law enforcement
security civil liberties civil rights
privacy
different range read it well it's it's
in the bill it's online
so let's let's just let's let's just go
that route
it's the preferable route to go why
wouldn't we
why wouldn't we so
just how just a quick follow-up on that
but how long are you willing to wait
when democrats seem to have
a real fear that what happened on
january 6
could occur again so how long are you
willing to wait before democrats decide
to just go at this on their own well we
want you know again these things take a
little longer time than
uh those who want immediate
gratification on an answer on something
we passed it yesterday what is your
answer today
it takes time for issues to be
socialized bills to be
to be uh reviewed and the rest so
uh again we want to bring it to the
floor when it is ready
i mean for them to bring it to the floor
when it is ready they may have some
uh modifications in it which we'll see
what they are then
again this is about um prioritizing
sequencing
honoring the report of general honor ray
and the inspectors general about what
needs to be done
but i would
like to have the trust that the senate
wants to find the truth as well
and let's just give them a chance to do
that without hanging something over them
about a timetable
or other uh options that exist for the
speaker of the house
follow up really quickly about police
reform we're approaching that may 25th
deadline on the anniversary of the death
of george floyd right now
democrats and republicans have said that
it doesn't seem like they would reach a
deal i mean what does that say about
does
i don't think they've said they're not
going to reach a deal
we've heard from senate senator cory
booker who have said uh who has said
that it's unlikely
right now that it looks like they'll
reach a deal by may 25th about may 25th
so that's a different story
i'm not a timetable person that those of
you may
i'm not a timetable person i don't want
to in uh shall we say
empower those who are opposed to it to
say well they didn't do it by the day
now
to do it when you're ready and it will
be in a reasonable amount of time
the hope would have been that we could
have done it by his birthday
but you can't do it until it's ready in
the best possible way
and that is more valuable than
having it a couple of weeks early or
whatever so i i think
i have great confidence in karen bass i
think that um
we're with all due respect to your
question
it's unimportant in terms of the fact
that it will happen
is what is important uh we would have
liked to happen at a certain time
it's a legislative process we're
operating
under circumstances that are unusual
with uh
people not here karen bass says she will
stay next week to con
hopefully complete but to continue the
negotiations i
i have great deal of respect uh for
how this is being handled in a
bipartisan way
we're very proud of karen bass for what
she's done and again this
is not just about us the maneuvering
internally and inside is very important
but does that say about every bill
inside maneuvering can only get you so
far
the outside mobilization is what
makes all the difference and the outside
mobilization we saw
more than one year ago after may 25th
was something that we'd never seen
before across the world
people in the streets for days if not
weeks
millions of people speaking out
against what happened to george floyd so
there's opportunity we'll have
legislation
i don't think we should bemoan the fact
of what day it is
as long as it is imminent and soon and i
think it will be
thank you all very much
oh my okay
you